well Jason Nichols is right in the
middle of this debate he's an actual
professor he teaches african-american
studies the University of Maryland and a
frequent guest in this show
professor thanks for coming on thank you
for having me talk so it seems like kind
of a would be a baseline for a
university to have pretty much absolute
freedom of speech a prerequisite for
freedom of thought what's the point of
having colleges if you can't say
whatever you think well I think number
one in society we don't have complete
freedom of speech of course you know
there's libel there's defamation there
is you know threats of violence and
inciting violence yes those are limits
on free speech so I think we have this
idea that freedom of speech means that
you can say anything and no we know what
it is because Brandenburg versus Ohio in
1967 the famous Supreme Court case very
specifically outlined the boundaries of
free speech and so libel is not allowed
of course imminent threats of violence
are not allowed but everything else is
allowed everything else is allowed and
you would but it's not allowed at Apple
or Amazon or some big authoritarian
company but colleges exist to be an
oasis in the middle of our commercial
society for free thinking so now why
would they be the places where free
thinking is punished most aggressively
no I agree that you know there there are
many cases and you and I actually
discussed you know a case a little while
ago where there was a college professor
who said something he shouldn't have
said and then all of a sudden people are
talking about oh he needs to be fired
try to this is why we actually have
tenure right is you know to protect
people so that they can say what it is
that they want but there have been all
these attacks there are these people who
are trying to put limits on what it is
you say and I think that that's you know
problematic but you know I think overall
colleges do protect freedom of speech so
what would happen if you went in into
your class and say yeah I kind of like
that Donald Trump and what do I like
about him I like the family separation
policy like the wall he's right that
Mexico doesn't send us its best there's
kind of red portions of a Trump speech
so how'd that work out for you I don't I
don't well I think students would
disagree and they'd have every right to
disagree of course they would I would
never contest that right as a matter of
fact even if they protested me that's
part of their First Amendment right
oh you're not getting no debate from me
on that I believe in the free exchange
of ideas and despite the efforts to shut
us down and shut us up we're still doing
it but if you said that in a faculty
meeting no one would engage people would
just say you know what you're some I
know you're african-american but you're
obviously some kind of freaky bigot you
don't mean they would treat you like
they treated Kanye West like no one
would engage you would say let's talk
through those ideas you you really think
the family separation policy is a good
idea
no they would shouting you would know
well I think people would disagree and I
think they would have every right to the
whole any of the colleges you say one
thing I see another then we talk about
them to get to wisdom isn't that the
goal but I think this the the
conversation doesn't always have to be
comfortable every time we can yell at
each other we can sit there and try to
shut one another down that's part of
free speech of course I guess the macro
question is have you ever met a group of
people with smaller Minds than those who
teach at America's colleges less open to
new ideas to challenging with truly
challenging concepts I think that's what
we literally do on college campuses
really is challenge concepts and
challenge popular ideas I think number
one you know about this one you go next
faculty mean so yeah just for the record
abortions murder let me tell you
something every semester we have
abortion activists who come out and
litter the campus with pictures of
aborted fetuses
yeah and their pregnant women who are
walking across campus crying and all
these kinds of things it's still there
First Amendment question is I'm just
saying I just wanna complain but what
people complain people come but what
would your colleagues say if you said
that I'm sure they'd be disgusted and
they they they'd be upset with me
it wouldn't be open to like but they
should be because they're not supposed
to be small-minded they're supposed to
be brought by oh these are people who
probably studied the issue and people
who study for a living or done well
amazingly that's the irony wrapped in
the riddle you are none of those things
which is why we're so grateful that you
come on the show thank you thanks a lot
so just you